emergency exit which leads directly
outside
fire number four and mccx will go into a
sterile cockpit and lock down for the
duration of the time the landscape
system is armed
large hole at this time you may proceed
with arming the crew around for movement
after that arming
crew arm for movement
minus 45 minutes and counting you've
just started the spacex launch director
give the
final execution instructions to the
launch team access arm retraction
started
we're ready for propellant load that'll
begin about 10 minutes before that we've
got crew access arm to retract happening
now and then arming in the launch escape
system everything continues to look good
for an on-time launch of falcon 9 with
axiom 1 mission
dragon spacex for tablets
as we prepare to step into les arming i
need you to verify that the elastic
bands are over the corners of all of the
ipads in the vehicle
[Applause]
all right copy that thank you mla and
for awareness that last call came in
pretty quiet so if you could speak up on
the upcoming calls that'd be great
thanks
[ __ ]
okay we'll give you an update here
inside a 43 minutes crew access arm has
retracted from the dragon spacecraft
next up we've got launch escape system
arming
and at t minus 45 minutes or t minus 35
minutes we'll begin loading propellant
onto the falcon 9.
so right now falcon 9's go dragons go
weather looks good and the range areas
are also cleared for launch so kate john
everything is looking good
inside of 42 minutes
everything continues to go well waiting
now for launch escape system army
endeavor spacex for launch escape system
go ahead aren't they
all right mla at this time i can give
you a go to step through section seven
of four decimal 100 close visors and arm
the launch escape system
that should work
spacex endeavor visors are closed we are
arming the launches cave system
dragon spacex launch escape system is
verified armed
all right there you heard it the launch
escape system is now armed you can see
there the crew in their seats with the
visors down
launch escape system um you know is the
first of its kind escape system um it
provides escape capability all the way
to orbit it's a really
important function to have um obviously
no intention of using it today but
that's what those call outs were there
back and forth that we just heard
right and as we heard earlier too from
administrator bill nelson um you know
the importance of low earth orbit so
speaking of just how valuable low earth
orbit is the crew of x1 will be
conducting a tremendous amount of
science over the course of their eight
days on board the iss and not only does
that include 25 axiom managed studies
but it also includes the axiom crew
participating in efforts that extend far
beyond this mission some of those we
actually looked at earlier one of these
broader studies is a series of health
monitoring tests before and after the
flight a few days ago i was able to
connect with dr emmanuel riketa to talk
about the ongoing research this crew
will participate in on behalf of the
translation research institute for space
health also known as trish here's our
conversation
dr ritkatsa welcome it is wonderful to
get to talk to you uh please introduce
yourself and tell us what is trish
absolutely my name is emmanuel richetta
and i'm the chief medical officer at the
translational research institute for
space health and i'm also faculty at
baylor college of medicine in houston
texas
the translational research institute for
space health or trish
we're partners to the human research
program at nasa and one of our main
goals is to find and fund new disruptive
research that is high risk but
potentially high reward
with the end goal of keep
humans healthy both in space and on
earth and we have been working with
commercial spaceflight missions since
last year and axiom one is our fourth
commercial spaceflight mission that's
really fascinating can you tell us a
little bit more about your primary areas
of focus or what you're studying on this
mission yeah so trish focuses mainly on
the high priority areas of human
spaceflight research
and
i would say the three highest priority
areas are radiation
behavioral issues that come from being
isolated and confined in space and the
third one is how your body changes uh
while you're in a different gravity
field either a 0g environment like in
space or during different gravity fields
when you're in the moon or mars okay
interesting so what kind of systems or
hardware are you working with
specifically to capture this data for
this mission the hardware that we're
using is absolutely optimized to provide
number one the the highest quality data
while uh you know being still easy to
use easy to implement
uh and being the lowest burden to to the
um to the astronauts
so to collect all of these data for
example uh vision changes we have been
using a small device is roughly the size
of a shoebox that you can see here come
this year with me so this is basically
like having an optometrist on a box
basically the only thing that you have
to do is just just grab it put it on
your eyes
look at an object that is roughly six
feet away from you and after a few
seconds you get a prescription of your
glasses right here so as i was saying um
if there's any changes on astronauts
during these missions we'll be able to
see how that changes with this device
we're also looking i was mentioning that
behavioral changes how being in an
isolated confined environment has any
behavioral aspects and for this one we
have been using a small tablet like this
one
also to test the sensory motor
adaptation that the balance disorders
and the space motion sickness we're
using a device like this and for each of
the of the crew members we have a set of
hardware like this and
it fits
the four sets of hardware fits on a
medium-sized
suitcase so it is it is really easy to
move uh wherever it needs to go uh for
for launch and uh advancing
that's wonderful so what are some of the
intended outcomes or goals of the
research you're doing
yeah so some of the outcomes uh and one
of the
main applications um number one for
space flight that that we want to get
from from this research is that short
durations missions like action one are
very very relevant in the context of
artemis missions when we go back to the
moon the first missions are going to be
roughly the same duration as action one
so anything new that we learn from these
missions is going to be absolutely
valuable really
every new piece of data we collect in
space flight could potentially solve and
be that that last piece of the puzzle
that we're looking to to complete what
we need to know
dr riketa thank you so much for speaking
with us today we wish you the best of
luck
it is my pleasure thank you
all right we are about
30 minutes out from launch of the
historic ax1 mission
it has taken an enormous effort from an
incredibly dedicated and hardworking
team to get to this moment and that team
wanted to take an opportunity to wish
the crew of ax1 well and godspeed
hey x1 we're so happy for you guys i
just want to let you know we've got you
here on the ground in mission control so
fly high and have some fun from all of
us here at the integrated performance
team we want to wish you luck on your
pioneering mission to the iss and hope
to see you in a couple years when ax h1
launches it is not only an immense honor
to get to watch your monumental mission
but also to be able to support you on
your journey towards this day as well
hey guys can't wait for this mission we
put a lot of hard work in we're excited
for you all to uh have a great time up
there and good luck thank you for
helping set an important precedence
ahead of a very bright future good luck
ax1 crew let's conquer space hasta
brando
we want to send you all off with good
wishes in this incredible journey
it has been such an honor to watch and
support you guys as you prepare for this
moment i'm so proud of each one of you
for the dedication the long hours and
the hard work you've put into making
this a meaningful vision hello action
astronauts thanks for sticking up to the
plate for this amazing journey you guys
have trained hard you've waited a long
time and this is now happening safe
travels on this historic mission for the
first private astronauts to go to the
iss it's happening
wave to us from up above because we'll
be thinking of you from down below we're
the axiom safety team
we just want you to know that we are
really proud of you and we've got your
back we're wishing you a safe and
successful mission and we'll see you
when you get back on the ground hi guys
we're the axiom soft goods team and we
just want to wish you a good mission and
get back safely it's a real pleasure to
be talking with you guys right now and
we're super excited for you i'm here to
cheer you on along with the entire crew
systems team
thanks for everything you're doing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i wish you all the very best
the greatest of success and the most fun
and the most challenging interesting
thing in your life
go big and enjoy your time on the iss
we'll see you back on the ground hey
guys i am so proud of the axiom one crew
it's so fun to be a part of something
bigger than you and to contribute most
important thing to remember guys
take some time to look out the window
and appreciate where you are
it's space
[Music]
we're t minus 31 minutes and 40 seconds
counting down
to the first all-private astronaut
mission to the international space
station
a few minutes ago falcon 9 propellant
loading began on time at t minus 35
minutes
rp1 fuel loading is underway on both the
first and second stages
liquid oxygen loading is underway on the
first stage
now we'll finish up
fuel loading on the second stage at
about t minus 20 minutes doesn't take
very long and then we'll begin loading
liquid oxygen on the second stage at
about t minus 16 and a half minutes
we'll continue propellant loading on
falcon 9 up until about t minus two
minutes
now speaking of propellants the dragon
spacecraft was loaded with its
propellants about a week and a half ago
just a few miles down the road from the
launch site at what we call dragon land
in order to fly dragon needs a fuel and
an oxidizer start of stage one
cryohelium loading for the fuel we use
monomethylhydrazine or mmh
and nitrogen tetroxide or nto for
oxidizer
now together these propellants feed the
draco engines that will maneuver dragon
on orbit changing its attitude uh
raising its orbit to get to the space
station but that propellant also serves
a second purpose and that would be to
use in the eight super draco engines
that would power the launch escape
system in an escape scenario
but right now on
pad 39a nice view of falcon 9 with
dragon there you can see the crew access
arm has retracted away from the dragon
spacecraft
the four-person crew is inside dragon
right now the launch escape system is
armed propellant is going into the
falcon 9.
so since we are at this stage with
launch escape system arm that means
there's eight super draco engines inside
the crew dragon are ready if needed to
launch the capsule away from the falcon
9 rocket in an instant should there be
any kind of emergency associated with
the rocket or the pad we have the
ability to use a launch escape system
right now if it was needed
a couple other status items
weather as you can see looks good
probability of violating the launch
commit criteria is less than 10 percent
the only thing we're watching is wind
gusts but we believe
having seen the the wind for the last
several hours
everything continues to look good that
should not be an issue
weather is also good in the atlantic
ocean should we need to use a launch
escape splashdown site for the dragon
capsule
we've also got upper altitude winds
we've been checking out
balloons have been released by the range
here recently
we continue to look good for upper
altitudes as falcon 9 flies through the
periods of maximum dynamic pressure
and finally on the range of course we
have cleared the danger areas the hazard
the caution areas everybody's out of
there except the four-person crew up in
the dragon capsule very top of the ride
you can see in the picture
so coming up t-minus 28 minutes 30
seconds everything continuing to look
good on falcon 9 with dragon for the
axiom 1 mission
let's take a moment now to get
acquainted with the vehicles that you
see there on your screen that's a live
view of falcon 9 with dragon
our spacecraft on top
falcon 9 rocket is a rocket um to the
falcon 9 rocket with a dragon spacecraft
on top uh together stands about 215 feet
which is almost 30 feet taller than the
leaning tower of pisa in italy
which is 130
183 feet
falcon 9 is a reusable two-stage
liquid-fueled rocket which means that
it's kind of like two rockets in one the
first stage and the second stage very
cool
so i'm talking about that first stage
the first stage is the bottom two thirds
of the vehicle that you see there has a
nice patina it's been reused a little
bit it's covered in soot from a previous
mission that first stage is responsible
for accelerating falcon and dragon
through the earth's atmosphere and into
space
to do that it has nine merlin engines at
the bottom of that first stage prior to
liftoff the falcon 9 first stage is
loaded up with nearly 1 million pounds
of fuel and liquid oxygen and the merlin
engines on the first stage are optimized
for sea level these achieve 190 000
pounds of thrust during ascent and
descent
the first stage accelerates the vehicle
through the earth's atmosphere into
space and then separates the rest of the
rocket at about two and a half minutes
into flight
from there the first stage will do what
no other orbital class rocket in the
world can do it'll make its way back to
earth and target a landing on our drone
ship a shortfall of gravitas which you
see there on your screen
the seas
look great the blue skies i i don't
think it could be any more picture
perfect no it's like a desktop right
there i think
our drone ships are essentially
autonomous powered space ports that
allow our rocket to land over the ocean
uh for reference our drone ships are
equivalent to the size of a football
field so uh while it may have looked
kind of small on your screen they're
actually pretty ginormous in real life
it's got to be to hold a rocket right
as man as mentioned previously falcon 9
is a two-stage rocket it's two rockets
in one above the first stage is the
second stage now the second stage has a
single merlin vacuum or mvac engine
which ignites after the first stage
now the second stage is essentially a
smaller version of the first stage and
whereas the first stage is designed to
power the vehicle out of earth's
atmosphere in the forces of gravity the
second stage is specifically designed to
operate in the vacuum of space
the second stage powers the dragon
spacecraft to its specific specific
targeted drop-off point in orbit
the dragon spacecraft is capable of
carrying up to seven passengers to and
from earth orbit and beyond but for
today's mission it is carrying four
members of the axiom one crew
it is the first private spacecraft to
take humans to the space station and the
only spacecraft currently flying that is
capable of returning significant amounts
of cargo to earth like the falcon 9
rocket the dragon spacecraft is also
reusable today will be the third flight
to space uh for this dragon spacecraft
uh that the axiom one crew is flying in
today uh the previous flights for this
this capsule supported were uh recently
the crew 2 mission and before that the
demo 2 mission uh which was our first
human space flight mission pretty
incredible yeah
now as we await t0 in just under 25
minutes the ground operations teams are
doing a series of system checks to make
sure both dragon and falcon 9 are ready
for launch let's take a look at what the
ascent portion of this mission will look
like
right so once we hit t minus zero we
will watch falcon 9 and dragon lift off
from historic launch pad 39a and make
their ascent
at about 50 seconds into flight falcon
9's engines will throttle down to help
pass through the period of maximum
dynamic pressure on the rocket or what
we typically refer to as max-q
it's worth noting that once we hit max-q
the vehicle will be going supersonic
once we're through the period of maximum
dynamic pressure we can throttle up our
merlin engines again from there at about
two and a half minutes into flight we
have a series of three events that
happen in rapid succession the first of
which is miko or main engine cut off
this is where all nine merlin engines
shut off in preparation for stage
separation which as the name suggests
that is where the first stage detaches
from the second stage with the first
stage making its way back to earth for
landing as the second stage continues on
its journey with the third event
right now ses one or second engine start
one is where the merlin vacuum engine
lights up and propels the second stage
along with our ax1 crew into orbit
as stage two heads towards its targeted
drop-off orbit stage one will execute
two burns in order to make its way back
to earth the first stage is the entry
burn where three of the merlin 1d
engines will reignite and then shut down
this helps to slow the stage down in
preparation for entry back into earth's
atmosphere
while the first stage is heading back to
earth the second stage will cut off its
singular merlin engine and that was
ignited right after stage separation
once this happens we'll wait for
confirmation of good orbital insertion
about 90 seconds after dragon gets into
orbit falcon 9 will land back on earth
the landing burn which is a single
engine burn will bring the vehicle's
speed down rapidly in order to land on
the drone ship
at about nine and a half minutes into
the mission
and while falcon 9's first stage is
landing dragon is preparing to separate
from the second stage about three
minutes after the second stage gets into
orbit we should have a great view of
dragon with this four-person crew
drifting away from the second stage
now once dragon is a short distance away
it will begin checking out its draco
maneuvering thrusters to make sure
dragon continues to increase separation
distance from the second stage
and lastly the nosecone deploy sequence
will initiate just before t plus 12
minutes and finish around t plus 15
minutes uh and this sequence will expose
dragon's docking mechanism in advance of
its arrival at the international space
station
so uh as you can tell it's it's a pretty
jam-packed 12-minute deal pay attention
pay close attention to what you're
listening to don't blink
with all that in mind uh let's head back
over to dan hewitt for an update uh from
the iss team over at johnson space
center dan
hey thanks kate now inside the room the
international space station flight
control room flight director scott
stover is leading the teams right now
but just about four hours ago nasa
flight director diane daly gave a go on
behalf of the combined iss team to the
spacex mission director just saying that
iss or the space station was go for
launch now to get there we've got a list
of flight rules basically just
guidelines for all of the major systems
we have to make sure are functioning
onboard station before we can give a go
to launch another crew up there so we're
looking at everything from those core
critical command and control computers
verifying we have a good communication
path through our tracking and data relay
satellites
ensuring that the atmosphere all of the
life support systems on board are
functioning even the mechanical systems
like the docking port where this mission
is headed so
we're expecting today's flight to be
about a 20 and a half hour journey from
launch to docking
with the crew dragon endeavor headed
towards the node 2 zenith that's the
space facing port on the top
of node 2 the harmony module onboard the
station and once they get there they're
going to get welcomed by the expedition
67 crew which is made up of seven
individuals right now four from our
spacex through crew three mission with
three nasa astronauts and one esa
european astronaut uh and they're joined
by three cosmonauts that just arrived on
station about two weeks ago now so it's
going to take them about 20 and a half
hours to get there that docking right
now is targeted for 11 45 gmt on
saturday at 6 45 am here in houston 4 45
for the teams over in hawthorne and so
once they get there they'll be able to
get out of their suits on board the
dragon spacecraft uh while the team
onboard station moves into what's known
as uh
the hatch operations uh station
commander tom marchand's gonna be
pressurizing that small area between
dragon
and the station hatches we expect it to
be a little under two hours from docking
to hatch open and then we'll welcome the
ax-1 crew on board the space station so
a lot to come with that 20 and a half
hour journey but all that's gonna start
with a launch so i'll send it back over
to hawthorne as you get into the final
phases of the countdown back over to you
john
right well dan as you mentioned it all
starts with the launch and kate it's
looking like it's getting pretty busy
here people are excited about seeing a
launch right yeah we're just now under
20 minutes until liftoff um as you could
probably tell by the the noise uh the
crew here to be the the crowd here in
hawthorne we're at spacex headquarters
in hawthorne california
is starting to gather uh just beyond
mission control here in the building and
uh you might be able to tell by the
ambient noise in addition to the live
production noises that you also hear you
know we are in a rocket factory um but
yeah you can see there the crowd is
starting to grow behind the mission the
team there at hawthorne mission control
now we saw dan speaking earlier from
mission control in johnson there is a
mission control center
in florida where the spacex teams are
also gathered
in firing room four and then we have the
the launch view the mission control
center here there's a shot of our firing
room 4 there in florida at cape
canaveral you can just
barely make out pad 39a there in the
distance there through the window
um might be wondering why all the
different mission control rooms the one
in johnson uh as dan was saying you know
that's really mission control for the
international space station and those
operations the control room that you see
there is for everything leading up to
launch um as soon as falcon 9 lifts off
uh responsibility and control transfers
to mission control center here in
hawthorne uh so just a quick explanation
for why why so many rooms with computers
exactly yeah in addition to all the
teams gathering here we've got teams of
our own gathering in houston at axiom
headquarters you can see there on your
screen axiom mission control with
the lovely axiom family behind them
looking in proudly
all right well you know dan mentioned
that you know first we have launch then
we've got run to do undocking and then
we've got eight days of jam-packed
activity on the iso so busy yeah and
docking day is not it's not just a ride
to space right you you get up there you
open that hatch and crew is working i
got a little chance to look at some of
their timeline um and as soon as they
open that door they are getting invited
in they are getting trained on some
emergency procedures and then stepping
right into payload activity stowage
transfers um and just generally getting
acclimated but they're working before
they go to sleep and the work doesn't
stop there
um it sounds a lot like everything
leading up to launch itself you know
everything is scheduled planned um even
you know we know that even sleep time is
scheduled on the iss it's something
that's uh incredible to me is that not
only do you have work to do but you know
your science experiments and that kind
of stuff not only do you have to get
some sleep where you can but you also
have to exercise right the exercise time
uh which can be a couple hours
all right so good news there we have
begun locks load liquid oxygen loading
on second stage
so that is currently underway for first
and second stage as well as loading of
rp-1 uh which is our fuel on both first
and second stage right
right and again you know some of those
things that you talked about it's all
following a timeline right and we are
listening for those important cues along
the way that we're hearing on these nets
or on the loops um
uh listening for where are we along in
that timeline so we know exactly where
we are in terms of launch as we count
down at just t minus 15 from launch
yeah so i'm looking uh at my dashboard
here it looks like fuel load on second
stage is now complete uh so we're
beginning that locks load as we just
heard locks load and fuel load continues
on uh first stage
axiom crew continuing to wait
following along with everything
happening there with the touchscreen
displays there above them as well as
their tablets strapped to their legs
right everything continuing to look
nominal for liftoff in just about 15
minutes
and as we approach uh that liftoff in
these final moments of our countdown to
launch axiom space founders cam geffery
and mike staffordini wanted to take a
moment to reflect on this mission
well this moment for me and michael is a
very special moment
in a beginning of many beginnings right
the launch of ax1
going to international space station as
part of our journey to build the first
private commercial space station and
we're so grateful to be here and
delighted uh at this moment as part of
this incredible journey to commercialize
and privatize low earth orbit on behalf
of cam and i we'd like to thank the
entire team that's made this historic
journey possible the spacex team in
particular has done a tremendous job of
prepping our crew for launch on their
transportation vehicle the crew itself
has done a fantastic job of getting
themselves ready and playing their
research
nasa of course we can't do this without
nasa's leadership and support and to
each of you in the axiom space family we
couldn't have done it without you we're
looking forward to a bright future
together
t minus 14 minutes seven seconds and
continuing to count down
everything is still looking good for
launch of falcon 9 and dragon that'll
occur 17 minutes and 12 seconds after
the hour
as a recap falcon 9 began propellant
loading at t minus 35 minutes
we just heard loading of the rp1 fuel
the kerosene fuel on stage 2 was
completed right on time at t minus 20
minutes
we still got fuel going on to the first
stage looks like we're about 90 or so
full right now
fuel loading will finish up at t minus
six minutes and we'll hear that call out
in the countdown
meanwhile densified liquid oxygen is
continuing to load onto both the first
and second stages
first stage will close out at t minus
three minutes the second stage we just
began loading liquid oxygen at t minus
16 and a half minutes just a few minutes
ago
that'll wrap up at the t minus two
minute mark
now we load the liquid oxygen as late as
we can in the countdown
it's densified that means it's ultra
cold
well below the boiling point of liquid
oxygen that lets us put as much as we
can on the vehicle for performance and
getting it on board the vehicle just
before liftoff means it won't warm up
where you start to lose the ability to
put liquid oxygen onto the stages into
the tank
uh in the quantities we want so it stays
nice and cold it doesn't bleed off and
that gives us the performance we need on
falcon 9.
continuing on falcon 9 checkouts of the
thrust vector controllers what we call
tvc wiggles you may hear that term
they're coming up we're also going to be
doing throttle valve checkouts on the
merlin engines that helps control the
power of the engines as we go through
flight for example you hear a throttle
down and throttle up as we prepare for
the period of maximum dynamic pressure
as we come up on the 12 minute mark
the range continues to be go
uh roadblocks are up all the hazard
areas are clear
airspace sea space is good
the weather is go beautiful shots you
can see here blue skies i'm looking
forward to some great views from the
cameras as we head into space and
finally on the dragon side the dragon
mission director and team they're
reporting no issues
we've done the communication checkouts
with the crew you can see the crew
access arm has retracted into the launch
position you can see dragon now with the
strong back of the transport erector and
the umbilicals going to drag and along
side of it
we've also armed the launch escape
system and obviously the crew is
strapped in the dragon capsule and
they're ready to go
final instructions of the crew will come
in about a minute and a half at t-minus
10. we'll listen to that the crew
displays will be configured for launch
and that setup will give the crew
insight into how the launch is
proceeding and it provides constant
updates on vehicle health
the t-minus five minutes will be in the
terminal count for dragon dragon will
transition to internal power going to
its onboard batteries and off of the
external ground power
we're going to hear continued call outs
on the countdown net as we go from t
minus 10 to zero and then as we fly
after t zero and liftoff we'll hear
call-outs as we head into space
that'll be letting the crew know as they
reach each of the milestones
now next big event coming up at t minus
10 minutes is we're going to do launch
commit criteria and final instructions
will be going to the crew
one other thing that you will hear
is during ascent you may hear one alpha
one bravo two alpha
these are launch escape states as the
falcon 9 flies if a launch escape was
required
the crew on board knows where they are
passing various points in the countdown
and that would tell dragon what sequence
of events to execute to come off of the
falcon 9 and bring the crew back safely
down under the parachutes in the ocean
right now t minus 10 minutes let's
listen in to the countdown dragon spacex
confirmed crew displays are configured
for launch
spacex
[Music]
copy mla and on behalf of the entire
spacex team we're honored to have you
aboard endeavor for its third flight to
the international space station axiom
one marks a new step in commercial space
flight and research we wish you a great
mission good luck godspeed and enjoy the
ride
thanks for those words i've got a few of
my own i'm going to let my teammate say
it first though
and a few minutes before launching on
this journey
i wish to share with you the words of
the greek poet constantine kawasi that
will
describe the perspective of our
marvelous group
arriving there is what you are designed
for
but do not hurry the journey at all
better if it lasts
for years
to you so you are old
by the time you reach the island
wealthy with all you have gained on the
way
not expecting ithaca to make you rich
nitaka gave you this marvelous journey
that's the high x1
thank you veyton i'm going to continue
far less elegantly or eloquently but
he's sitting here on the precipice of
this new era of human space flight we do
so on the shoulders of professionals
at spacex nasa and exit
we want to thank all the teams at spacex
uh falcon 9 dragon
the watch team of course killed our team
and all of the folks in mission control
um and of course our training teams
this massive voice been sucking they're
the first time there's always hard and
there's no playbook it's all open field
running but with iss partnering
commercial video development and flight
operations
we've learned a lot and we'll continue
to do so
we want to thank kim and sup for their
vision but especially all the people at
action for putting this mission together
with the amount of miracles that they
perform
all of you make no mistake are the men
and the women in the arena their faces
are marred
metaphorically by their best sweat and
blood
when you strive valiantly
will have no place with their cold and
timid souls who know neither victory nor
defeat
the crew of the great ship endeavor is
ready to sell her proudly arthur
some heartfelt words there one engine
started
all right so there was a call that
we have begun to chill the engines
on the first stage so what we're doing
right now is flowing a little bit of the
super chilled liquid oxygen
through the turbo pumps on those m1d
engines there's nine of them at the base
of the first stage
and that's essentially bringing them
down to the temperature of that super
chilled liquid oxygen to
prevent any thermal shock to the
hardware and just before that calls some
really heartfelt words from commander
mla
and mission specialist ayton stibba
i really love hearing that commentary
stage 1 rpu load is complete
at this point in time the
at this point in time uh fuel is
fully loaded on both the first and
second stage locks loading continues
on both stages
coming up on five and a half minutes
kate's letting us know that we've got
the field load complete next is coming
up with t-minus five minutes dragon will
be transitioning uh configuration for
terminal count and going on its internal
battery power everything continues to
look good as we're counting down
dragon is in configure for terminal
count
falcon 9 tanks are pressing for strong
back retracts
heard the call out we're pressurizing
the tanks for strongback retract
we'll hear a sequence momentarily
strongback is retracting actually that's
the start of about a one minute sequence
about t-minus four minutes the clamp
arms that you can see there will open
and then
and then we will see the retract from
there
so we've heard the call out that's the
start of the sequence
doesn't mean that the clamp arms are
late opening
will take us a few more seconds
as you can hear the excitement and the
crowd is really growing here at spacex
headquarters at hawthorne california
there you can see the clamp arms have
begun to open
and next we should see the strong back
begin to retract
this structure is what we basically use
to transport uh the fully integrated
vehicle to and from the hanger
from the hanger to the launch pad and
there you can see that strong back
retraction has begun
everything continued to look
nominal uh as we're now under three and
a half minutes until launch
our p1 fuel is fully loaded on first and
second stage
it should be wrapping up locks load on
the first stage momentarily
and continuing to fill on second stage
stage one lux load is complete
we're under three minutes until liftoff
of the axiom one mission
dragon is in terminal count and is on
internal power
all right there we heard that dragon is
on internal power
as i was saying we're getting close the
crowds are growing the excitement is
palpable
you can see there on the left-hand side
of your screen mission control here in
hawthorne california just behind where
john and i are
um and then on the right-hand side that
looks like axiom mission control axiom
mission control in houston texas
everybody's waving and saying hey
all right at this point in time that
locks load on first stage is complete
so the first stage is now fully loaded
with all of its propellant
box load on second stage continues
as we've mentioned
before load is complete
all right so there's that call at this
point in time falcon 9 is an auto idol
dragon is fully loaded with all of its
propellants nearly 1 million pounds
of that propellant
next event coming up
right now
the gas closeouts we finished
pressurizing the storage tanks on board
the falcon 9 they gave the crew the
heads up may hear some loud landing
noises
we're also going to vent down the liquid
oxygen line that carried the
box up to the second stage
generates a typical large white cloud of
condensation around the strongback
big event coming up now t minus one
minute all the flight computers take
over let's listen in to the last minute
of terminal count
fts is armed falcon 9 is in startup and
now controlling
dragon is in countdown
dragon spacex go for launch
30 seconds
t-minus 15 seconds
ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one zero ignition
stop go falcon
[Applause]
together a new chapter begins godspeed
ax1
stage 1 propulsion is nominal
t-plus 38 seconds into this historic
mission flying crew on board dragon and
falcone telemetry nominal
stage one throttle down
throttling down in the preparation for
max dynamic pressure
falcon 9 is supersonic
the crew calling out one bravo should a
escape situation arise that tells the
dragonflight computer what profile to
fly using the super draco engines but
everything is looking good
on falcon 9.
we're getting nominal call-outs from all
the engineers and a great view from the
ground camera and the on-board camera
underway
beginning to chill in the second stage
turbo pump in preparation for its
ignition coming up in just over half a
minute from now
coming up on about three and a half g's
acceleration for the crew
we'll begin throttling down the merlin
engines to hold that period that level
of acceleration
next event coming up we're going to get
main engine cut off
get stage separation and ignition of the
second stage engine you've heard the
throttle down call out we're holding
three and a half g's for the crew
and mikko
[Applause]
successful stage separation ignition of
the second stage engine on the left the
titanium grid fins beginning to slowly
deploy great views from the first stage
camera the first stage now begins a slow
flip maneuver you can see the white
nitrogen gas plumes
as we reorient for an entry back through
the earth's atmosphere a little bit
later
in the plus count
second stage we see the engine nozzle
glowing red
everything continuing to look good on
the second stage
you should be hearing call-outs coming
up to the crew here shortly on how the
trajectory is looking
dragon spacex trajectory nominal
what we like to hear
signal bermuda
aos bermuda acquisition signal bermuda
tracking station now getting telemetry
from the second stage of the falcon 9
with the dragon on top
two plus four minutes 10 seconds
everything continues to be nominal first
aid coasting to apogee and then it will
come back down for landing on the drone
ship second stage partway through its
lengthy burn to get the crew into orbit
so kate four and a half minutes in
everything continues to look good
what a
absolutely picture perfect
liftoff
we've got a live view of the crew inside
dragon endeavor
looks like
uh everyone is still pretty comfy
as john had said earlier we got
trajectory nominal
all right good call out there that
trajectory is nominal uh
as john mentioned we got to about three
and a half g's there signal new
hampshire
on the left-hand side of your screen we
can see the first stage as it is making
its way back down to earth it's
targeting a landing on our drone ship a
shortfall of gravitas which is parked a
couple hundred miles off the coast of
florida out in the atlantic ocean
second stage on the right hand side
everything continues to be nominal there
as the mvac engine is powering the
second stage and dragon in denver
dragon endeavor
to its targeted drop-off orbit
absolutely beautiful views of both the
first and second stages
all right so coming up in about a minute
and a half
the first stage will execute the first
of two burns required for today's
landing attempt um at about t plus seven
minutes and thirty seconds we'll see the
entry burn begin
that's where the first stage will ignite
um the center engine first and then a
couple seconds later ignite two more
engines so a total of three engine burn
which will last about 29 seconds
the entry burn slows the vehicle down
significantly as it re-enters back into
the earth's atmosphere
the first stage sees high drag which
scrubs roughly 70 percent of that
velocity by the time that the landing
burn begins
stunning view where you can see the
curvature of the earth there on the left
hand side dragon spacex trajectory
nominal
there you can see the nitrogen gas
thruster so that's the puff of um gas
that you see there occasionally that's
used for
attitude control systems we also utilize
those grid fins that you see there are
four of them
placed around
the booster
and those grid fins also help steer for
a precise landing um
either stage one entry burn startup
stage two all right there we can see
that that entry burn has begun
we are targeting a landing on our drone
ship a shortfall of gravitas today
everything continuing to look nominal
with trajectory and
uh mvac performance there for our second
stage on the right hand side
so we are conducting the entry burn
previously the booster stage one entry
burn shut down
that entry burn helps slow the booster
down it was going about 25 times the
speed of sound
so we slow it down as it re-enters the
dense part of the earth's atmosphere
the next event is second engine cutoff
or seco one as you see it there on the
timeline at the bottom of your screen
it's attached to your terminal guidance
that's where we shut down the mbac
engine or second engine cut off
copy shannon
stage one transonic
note that our landing burn and second
engine cutoff uh will occur about the
same time
all right we've got a live view of the
crew inside dragon endeavor there on the
right hand side of your screen
stage one landing burn
landing burn has begun for the first day
domino orbit insertion
all right great news there dragon
endeavor
nominal orbit insertion
spacex endeavor we copied and it's great
to be here zero
stage one landing lake deploy spacex
dragon launch system
as you can see this falcon 9 has landed
for the fifth time
all the while great commentary there
while we can confirm the landing
pad
confirmed landing there of the first
stage booster also almost simultaneously
great news uh for the second stage we
heard that there was nominal orbit
insertion uh for crew dragon endeavor
there you can see a live view inside our
dragon
looks like the crew is
beginning to adjust to zero gene if you
look at the right hand side corner it
looks like we can see the zero g
indicator
that was one of mine
that was one of the things i really
wanted to see what they were going to
bring to their zrg indicator so i can't
wait it comes on it looks i can't quite
tell
pokemon
uh maybe okay well hopefully it'll it'll
come into closer view yeah if not we'll
get to ask them later hopefully yeah
great to see the crew here again
starting to
really getting their first taste of
microgravity yeah
oh it has ears oh it's a bunny is that
bumper i think it might be i think
that's thumper from bambi
love it
so right now uh the second stage is
basically preparing for uh dragon
separation um
we are the next step now that as we said
dragon has nominal orbital insertion the
second stage and dragon will separate
use there of our
mvac engine
now shut off
no longer glowing
that lovely shade of orange
right now the second stage is about 200
kilometers above earth
preparing now for stage separation
excuse me for dragon separation
for those of you that have just recently
joined us we had an on-time liftoff of
the axiom one crew they are now
in space and uh coming up to separation
from second stage at which point um they
will then begin to make their journey
continue their journey to the
international space station
the view that you're currently looking
at is inside the dragon trunk
which as you can see has just separated
from the second stage
at the amps of falcon
welcome to space thanks for flying
falcon 9.
you guys enjoy your trip to that
wonderful space station in the sky do
some great research for us
we'll see you back here underground
now stand by for some words from ld
and mla and and the rest of the crew
endeavor glad we got to have some fun
this morning
we'll probably be calling an early
weekend over here at the cape pass you
over to anna and the team you'll be in
good hands
godspeed endeavor enjoy the rest of your
flight cheers
hey mark it was a lot of fun i spent for
the guest we had a little bit more than
you today we thank you and your launch
team encouraged you and the falcon 19
that was a hell of a ride and was
looking forward to the next 10 days
all right some
nice words there from a couple of key
folks
my first quindar tone of the mission
yeah
i queued up right when i heard that
signal bermuda and new hampshire there
we can see
uh dragon endeavor
on its way to the international space
station it has separated there's a view
inside next we have nominal dehumidifier
activation service section draco
checkouts
there we can see over the shoulder of
space next to every copy
over the shoulder previously commander
mla was on the left and pilot larry
connor was on the right
live view inside the cabin they just got
the okay to lift their visors
all right
so we can see that everyone is
in space we can see that zero g
indicator floating around great view
there um of dragon endeavor now in space
with the axiom one crew on their way to
the international space station yeah i
mean this is a day of first you know
this is my first time getting to
participate in a launch like this is the
first for axiom and this is a first
first base flight and it's just
wonderful to see such a picture picture
perfect launch it really well we saw the
landing and we saw
orbital or uh zero g insertion at the
same time i mean that was perfect yeah
it was wonderful to see
all right well as i just said today's
launch is one for the history books so
to punctuate this milestone that nasa
and commercial companies are able to
achieve together we go now to kennedy
space center where megan cruz is with
nasa's kathy leaders
i am i'm here right now with the
associate administrator of nasa's space
operations mission directorate so great
to have you here kathy what did you
think of the launch oh my gosh it's
always like you know right in the
bottom of my throat i'm holding can't
breathe can't breathe yes but what a
beautiful beautiful sight yeah so good
to see it i want to tell everybody
working artemis one wet dress we're off
the range we're off the range for axiom
one and we can get moving but um you
always want to hear
the engine cut off you always want to
hear that second stage engines lighting
you always want to hear you know each of
these stages and we need to just
keep carefully working through
the different steps to get that crew
there to the international space station
safely yeah what does axiom 1 represent
axiom 1 and also future private
astronaut missions to the international
space station hey you know nasa's
original goal was to enable
commercial industry that was actually in
our original space act agreement so here
we are you know 60 years later
enabling that through our missions and
so i just feel like this is a
culmination of 60 years of work for us
and here we are once again getting to
see and for the first time the first
time getting to have commercial
you know private astronauts going to the
international space station and they'll
get to see what our government
the what they call in professional
astronauts doing their real work but
then also getting to do their work too
and it's a it's another place where
learning to peacefully work
in space i think is moving us forward
yeah so important and you know we just
watched axiom one lift off from that
launch pad right there behind us in a
couple of weeks we're going to see crew
4 launch from that same launch pad and
then just right next to it pad 39v we
have nasa's brand new space launch
system can you recall a busier time
we've had here at the space coast and
how is kennedy space center managing its
new role as this multi-user spaceport so
i think somebody else this is i mean bob
cabana had this dream of a multi-user
spaceport here so i think he should be
very very proud of his ksc team and
janet petro and her team are obviously
leading the way right now because this
is not easy to do it's not easy to go
make sure
all these people have all the
capabilities that are obviously working
with our air force
sister agency there too and making sure
that all these launches get supported in
a seamless way just an amazing job yeah
a lot of juggling that has to happen so
you know i just talked about sls we are
looking forward to the moon with that
launch later this year you know why is
it still so important to maintain a
presence in low-earth orbit when we're
looking towards the moon now because we
still don't have everything figured out
how to do things yet
for the moon and mars and really the
cheapest place for us to see a
differential gravity environment and for
the long term is still leo yeah and so
we've got to continue to do these long
duration flights keep doing our medical
protocols keep doing our physical
protocols keep testing out our equipment
through those long duration missions
it's only place where we can do that
right now and so
we still need to be able to have this
kind of a test bed for us to be
checking out and proving our protocols
our research our technology before you
go put somebody in the rocket that's
going to go to mars right so
just like always we prepare we get
ourselves ready and a lower orbit
destination is a perfect place to do
that and again how does us fostering
commercialization efforts in space how
does that free us up to pursue these
other dreams that we have as an agency
so you know the administrator today in
in the um
pre-mission conference he said
you know we right now are doing this is
our first step we're working with a a
commercial company to have them come to
our international space station we're
learning to work together and figuring
out how to work together and this is
going to be an important step for us
because moving forward we would actually
like to now be able to
buy a ride and time on orbit yeah with
the commercial company to be able to
have them do that and so this is the
first step of their learning from us and
that's learning from them and then in
the future you know we're going to have
space station for another eight years
but we would like by the early 2030s for
us to be flipping the rules yeah and
have our professional astronauts going
up and and checking and doing and
focusing on the research and technology
we need for exploration
but allowing commercial providers to be
doing the hard work of maintaining the
laboratory kathy we have an exciting
future i'm looking forward to seeing it
and thank you again for being here thank
you all right back to you dan
all right hey thanks megan it is great
to see the ax1 mission on orbit the team
here
uh with the space station already we're
ready to get them on board so their
journey just started they've got about
20 and a half hours until they're docked
to the space station again they're
headed for the zenith port on node two
that's the space facing one on the very
top uh with that docking scheduled right
now for 11 45 gmt on saturday
that is just about
645 i have a feather
and my right hand a hammer
and i guess one of the reasons uh we got
here today was because of a gentleman
named galileo a long time ago
who made a rather significant discovery
about falling objects in gravity fields
and we thought that
where would be a better place to confirm
his
findings than
on the moon
and so we thought we'd try it here for
you
the feather happens to be appropriately
a falcon feather
in la nasa
yesterday
is
you